order in the court. An insurance policy
isn't just a basic corporate receipt. It
is a formal contract defined under
article 305 of the new civil code as a
meeting of minds where one party binds
himself to give something or render a
service. To be legally enforcable, an
agreement must stand on four essential
elements. One, agreement consisting of a
clear offer by one party and an explicit
acceptance by the other. Two, competent
parties. The insurer must hold a valid
license to do business and the insured
cannot be a minor, mentally incompetent,
or a defined public enemy. Three, legal
purpose. The contract cannot run
contrary to law, morals, or public
interest. Four, consideration. the
premium payment value exchanged for the
assumption of loss. If an agreement
violates these pillars, it drops into
one of four defective categories.
Reissible contracts are technically
valid but can be legally set aside
because they cause distinct economic
damage or involve concealment or
misrepresentation.
Voidable contracts appear valid on the
surface but hold a structural legal flaw
like an agreement signed by a minor.
Uninforcable contracts occur when an
individual executes an agreement
completely lacking the legal authority
to do so. Void or inexistent contracts
have a purpose completely contrary to
law, morals, or public policy, like a
contract protecting an illegal drug
supply. They have zero lawful objective
and are void from day one. Section two
of the new insurance code formally
defines our subject as an agreement to
indemnify another against loss, damage,
or liability arising from an unknown or
contingent event. When you open up a
physical insurance policy, you will find
six standard highly structured
components. First is the preamble, which
states the core purpose of the contract,
identifies the two parties, and declares
that the premium must be fully paid.
Second is the insuring clause also known
as the operative clause which outlines
the insurer's formal agreement to pay if
the loss occurs during the period of
insurance due to a covered peril. Third
is the attestation clause which
officially confirms that the insurer has
authenticated the policy by signature.
Fourth is the policy schedule which logs
all user specific metrics like your
name, address, terms, premium rates and
the description or location of the risk.
Fifth are the conditions defining the
strict operational rights, exclusions
and claim duties of both parties. And
sixth are endorsements which are
separate attached documents used to
modify the base policy's original terms,
conditions, or scope. Oh, and keep an
eye out for a cover note. These are
crucial temporary contracts issued to
provide coverage for a maximum period of
60 days pending the formal issuance of
the final policy document. When a legal
dispute over text language arises,
courts use strict rules of construction.
Phrasiology must be interpreted based on
its plain, ordinary, and popular sense,
though strict technical meanings are
applied to technical terms. If a clause
is genuinely ambiguous, it is always
construed strictly against the insurer
and liberally in favor of the insured
because the client had zero say in
writing the text. And if the preprinted
terms contradict a handwritten or typed
edition, the written portion always wins
because it captures the true immediate
intention of the contract. This is
because insurance contracts possess
unique structural qualities. They are
aliatory meaning the outcome hinges
entirely on chance or an uncertain
event. They are contracts of adhesion
because the insured must accept the text
as written by the company. They are
personal meaning the contract is tied
explicitly to the specific character and
credit of the owner. If ownership of the
property changes, the insurance does not
automatically pass to the new owner.
They are unilateral, meaning only the
insurer makes a legally enforcable
promise to pay for losses after the
premium is received. And they are
conditional because the insured must
satisfy specific requirements before
collecting a dime.
Finally, let's step up to the bench and
look at the six general principles of
insurance that govern every single claim
evaluation. Principle one is utmost good
faith. Both parties must completely
disclose all material facts that would
influence risk decisions or premium
pricing. Breaking this via concealment,
neglecting to communicate a material
fact or misrepresentation where facts
failed to match assertions renders the
contract resessible. Principle two is
insurable interest. You must have a
legal relation to the subject matter
such that you suffer financially if it
is damaged and benefit from its safety.
For property insurance, this interest
must exist when the insurance takes
effect and when the loss occurs. For
life insurance, it must exist only when
the insurance takes effect. Principle
three is indemnity. This ensures an
insured is compensated for actual losses
sustained and placed back into the exact
same financial position occupied right
before the disaster. You are never
allowed to profit from insurance. Life
and personal accident insurance are the
explicit exceptions here. Indemnity can
be delivered via monetary payment,
reinstatement, repair min or article
replacement.
Principle four is subregation. A direct
corlary to indemnity. It allows the
insurer to stand in the shoes of the
insured and pursue legal remedies or
third-party recoveries against a
negligent party who caused the accident,
but only up to the exact amount paid out
on the claim. This prevents the insured
from recovering twice and profiting.
Principle five is contribution. This
applies when there is double insurance,
meaning multiple policies cover the same
interest, matter, and peril. Insurers
pay proportionately to the loss. If a
policy carries a standard contribution
clause, the insured losses the power to
arbitrarily pick one company to pay the
whole amount. All insurers pay their
ratable proportion.
Principle six is proximate cause. This
is the active efficient cause that sets
a seamless chain of events in motion,
bringing about a loss without the
intervention of any force started from a
new independent source. Proximity is
judged entirely by its operational
effectiveness, not by which event was
closest in time to the accident. All of
these parameters are governed by
Republic Act number 10,67,
otherwise known as the Insurance Code of
2013, which gives the insurance
commissioner full authority to regulate
companies, agents, and brokers alike.
That wraps up our masterclass text
transcript for module 1. You are now
fully armed with the knowledge. Scroll
directly down to interact with our FAQ
component and challenge the interactive
module quiz widget to lock in your
score. See you in the next module.